Good evening, and thank you for
coming to today's installment
of Life in the Universe,
brought to you by UA Science.
So first, I'd like to
point out that we're
very interested in
your participation.
And in other years,
what we've had
is answers and questions
from the audience, which
has become very complicated.
This year, we're going to do
something slightly different.
And what we're going
to do is, we're
going to have a panel discussion
which is going to be broadcast
by KUAT on the 20th of March.
And what I ask all
of you is to send us
your questions between now
and the 20th, so some of you
will be able to ask those
questions to the panel.
The panel will be on the 20th,
as I mentioned, at one o'clock
in the afternoon.
And I can tell you,
because I've been in a room
with these folks, that the most
interesting conversations I
have ever heard have been
the conversations between all
the speakers talking
to each other.
And now, they'll be able
to answer your questions.
The second that has to do with
the participation of the public
is, we're going to
inaugurate this year
an institute at the Biosphere.
And if you want to spend three
days and two evenings embedded
in science with scientists,
keep your eyes open.
Between now and when the
lecture series is over,
you'll have information
of how you can actually
be part of the Biosphere
2 institute this year.
And that's to give
Aspen Institute
a run for their money.
I'd like to thank the
folks that make it possible
for us to do this in a way
that it doesn't cost you
anything but the parking.
And I have to deal with
that, but the parking
is sort of the final frontier.
And there is a list of those
that make it all possible.
And in particular, we
should give an applause
to all of them.
And in particular, Ventana,
TEP, and the Arizona Daily Star
have been with us since day one.
They have made it possible.
They've made it possible for you
to know that this is going on.
And I thank them sincerely.
Now, another thing
that the folks that
pay for this allow us to
do is to have middle school
and high school
teachers take part
of this experience
in a deeper way,
so that they can actually
create curriculum and take back
to their classes.
And I'd like to ask the faculty
to stand up for a second,
so that we can all give
you a big applause.
And in particular, I'd like
two people to stand up.
John Pollard, who is
a person from the U
of A that's teaching them.
And Margaret Wilch, teach the
most extraordinary high school
teacher in the world.
It's Dr Wilch, because
she has an honorary degree
from the University
of Arizona in science.
All right.
Well, the first
day that you came
here, the first
Monday you came here,
you heard all about how
little we can actually
even define life.
And the reason for
that lecture is
that if we're going to
find life somewhere else,
we should know what
we're looking for.
And you heard that lecture,
and basically, it's hopeless.
But we are trying.
The second lecture went the
step of how do you actually
create life from chemistry.
So Donte Loretta pointed
out that the elements that
are required to create life were
not created at the Big Bang,
they were created when
the stars were formed.
And as the stars die, the
whole interstellar medium
becomes full of these elements,
like carbon and phosphorus
and nitrogen, which are
required to make DNA and so on.
So he tried to address
the question of,
how do you go from
chemistry to life?
And he was able to
at least address,
in some ways, how you get the
chemistry to maybe RNA or DNA.
And there's still the challenge
of how you make cells.
He didn't even go there.
Today, we're going to talk
about another mystery.
And that mystery is, how do
we get all of the biodiversity
that we have in a place like the
Earth from the simple building
blocks that we're
all made out of.
So Brian Enquist
will tell us today
about biodiversity, how it
starts, what keeps it going,
and the scaling laws in biology.
How do we scale up from a very
small animal to a very large
animal or plant?
So the idea of biodiversity,
how we make all
that we see from
the stuff that's
Donte Loretta was telling
us about last time
is an amazing mystery.
Now, Brian is an amazing
individual from the National
Science Foundation.
He's a Young Principal
Investigator Award.
These are very important things.
From the Ecological
Society of America,
he got one of the most
prestigious awards
as a young scientist.
And more importantly, Popular
Mechanics, of all places,
named him one of the 10 most
interesting young scientists
to follow.
So there you go, he
may have something
to do with cars as well.
So I leave you
with Brian Enquist.
Thank you.
It's an absolute
rush to be here.
What an amazing night
for science in Tucson.
But I think before
I get started,
this series would
not be possible
if it weren't for the brain,
drive, and passion of Joaquin.
So let's thank Joaquin.
For not only being our leader
in the College of Science
but also setting a good example
for what science should be,
not only in a real democracy,
but its role to play
in terms of creating dialogue.
Unlike most of the
other speakers,
I'm actually tweeting this,
so feel free to send me
a tweet if you want.
I'll try not to tweet
while I'm talking.
So what I want to
start with today
is actually one of my
favorite photos of the earth.
This was taken in
1968 by the crew
of one of the Apollo missions.
This was the first image a
human actually saw of the earth.
So this is the first photograph
of the Earth taken by a human.
And what's amazing is that
I don't study the universe.
I don't build a satellite.
I study life on Earth.
And so what I would
like to do today
is tell you a little bit
about life on Earth but also
what I find absolutely
amazing about life on Earth.
So let me show you one of
the places that we work.
This is the Kosnipata
Valley, this is in Peru.
It's right near
Manu National Park.
It's perhaps the most
biodiverse place on the planet.
We study the diversity
of plants and trees
along an elevational gradient.
So we go from tree line
at the top of the Andes,
we drop all the way down
to the Amazon basin.
And we want to understand what
not only controls the changes
in diversity that we see
along these gradients
but also how tropical
forests, how ecosystems work.
And we also want
to understand how
these organisms work,
in particular how
these trees work.
So when we go out on our various
different collecting missions,
we sample leaves, we climb
trees, we bring them down.
And we put them in these
pretty fancy bits of equipment
here, where we're actually
measuring their metabolism,
their photosynthetic rate.
We then take the
leaves, we process them
here in a field lab in the
middle of the rainforest.
Take those leaves,
we bundle them up,
and we bring them back to
the University of Arizona,
where we measure other
aspects of their metabolism,
such as nitrogen
content, phosphorus
content, isotopic various
signatures and so on.
And our ultimate
goal here is that we
want to understand how these
trees, these organisms, work.
But ultimately, we want to
understand how these ecosystems
will respond to climate change.
But we don't want
to understand how
they change over time
or across elevation,
but we want to be
able to predict what's
going to happen in the future.
Now, to try to bring in
the predictive sense,
we also work quite a bit on
developing mathematical theory.
And a lot of this math
is aimed to ultimately
boil down and kind of
get at these measurements
that we're taking
within the field
and take then, those
measurements in order
to scale up and
understand and make
predictions about how
these tropical forests work
but also how ecosystems work.
So this is really a search.
We're interested in
searching for generalities
in how life works.
We want to understand something
as vast as the Amazon ring
forest, which also you can think
of as the lung of our planet.
What happens in the Amazon
influences are global climate,
it influences the
rest of the biosphere.
So what can we do in order
then, to search for generalities
or rules about how organisms
work, how diversity responds
to changing climates, in
order to ultimately provide
a more predictive
framework for biology?
So is Earth the only
planet with life?
I guess the quick
answer is, I don't know.
But as a biologist,
what I want to know
is what is really unique
about life on Earth?
Now, based on what we
know about life on Earth,
if we found life
elsewhere, what is
our best guess or best
prediction in terms
of what would it be like?
And if we could
then have some sort
of prediction, what would those
predictions then be for life?
So what I would like
to do in this talk
is counter two different views
about biology and arguably
about life in the universe.
But is life on Earth
really dictated by chance
or is it deterministic?
Now, in studying biology
for quite some time, what
I'm actually impressed
with is that I
think there's a very big
division within biology.
Well, maybe division
is too harsh of a word.
But it seems that biology really
does struggle with these two
different worldviews on life.
In particular, is
life due to chance,
or is life deterministic?
So on the one
hand, life on Earth
is amazing and
intricate and diverse,
but the thinking goes
that it's actually
arisen due to
multiple events that
are essentially unpredictable.
On the other hand, we
could also make arguments
that life on Earth is
highly deterministic,
and that we can
ultimately boil things
down to general rules and
principles which have guided
the diversification of life.
So what about chance?
So when we step back and
we look at the world,
and actually this is one
of my favorite paintings
I should say, by Jan Brueghel.
This is an 1613, Noah's Ark.
When we step back and look
at the diversity of life
on the planet, it
really is amazing.
There are small organisms.
There's big organisms.
There's organisms
that fly, organisms
that burrow in the earth.
All the way from
microbes all the way up
to the macroscopic,
huge organisms
that we share the planet with.
And it's actually amazing.
If you study
biological processes,
biological processes operate
at the subcellular scale,
all the way up to the
scale of the biosphere.
So basically, life
operates over 21 orders
of magnitude in scale.
So that's a number,
take a number
and move the decimal
point 21 times,
that's a huge range that
biology is operating over.
But is it all really by chance?
So when I graduated from high
school and went to college,
I decided that I want to
be a biologist, because I
loved various organisms, I loved
the diversity of the Earth.
I love going out
and understanding
how living things worked.
When I decided to
be a biology major,
my parents gave me a book,
and it was this book.
This is a book by Stephen
Jay Gould entitled
Wonderful Life,
The Burgess Shale
and the Nature of History.
And what's interesting
about this book
is that it really struck
a chord in me early on.
And I kind of assumed
that well, this
is how in general all
biologists really think.
But it also kind of haunted
me, because it spelled
out a view of the world that,
if true, from my perspective,
can't be correct.
How can it be that all of life
and the diversity that we see
today is due just to chance?
So according to
Gould, chance was
and is one of the decisive
factors in the evolution
of life on Earth.
And the paths then, that life
has taken since essentially,
life arose at the beginning
and evolved then, continuously
to today, these
various paths then
were actually constrained
by various historical events
well outside of the control
of anything biological.
Effectively, these
random historical events
and accidents.
So that was in 1989.
Now, what's interesting
is that Gould
takes a very interesting picture
about how the world actually
works.
And within that
book, he actually
asked the reader to do
a thought experiment.
In particular, if we were to
take the long history of life,
all the way from present
day all the way back
to 3.5 billion years ago,
the estimated origin of life,
if we redid evolution,
that is if we replayed
the tape of life-- in
putting this together,
I was thinking about
my kids and trying
to explain to them this thought
experiment about rewinding
the tape.
And I was like, oh, yes, they
don't have tapes anymore.
So this is a dated analogy.
But anyways, if we rewind the
tape, go back to the beginning
and play the play
of evolution again,
would we get the same
thing in the end?
So that was the
thought experiment.
So what if we could
go back in time,
and what if we could watch
evolution happen again?
What would it be like?
So Gould in particular
focused on a period
of time in the Cambrian
here, 541 million years ago.
I'm sorry, going
to the Precambrian.
So during this time,
this was essentially
then, the biological
equivalent of the Big Bang.
During this time,
the diversity of life
really exploded, and we see
all of these various different
forms of life.
So Gould focused on one example,
in particular the organisms
and the animals then found
then within the Burgess Shale.
The Burgess Shale then stems
from the middle Cambrian,
it's about 505
million years old.
It's perhaps one of the
most famous fossil beds
in the world.
The Burgess Shale is located
here in Alberta, Canada,
it's in the Canadian Rockies.
And so you can go
here and sample,
and you get these amazing
well preserved fossils.
These fossils preserved
soft parts then of the body.
And you can go through
and you can really
get a really good snapshot
of essentially a whole living
ecosystem, all the various
different organisms then
that lived during that time.
So during this time, life really
was a bizarre and alien world.
If we were able to time
travel and go back and look
at these various different
organisms, many of us
would think that we
were in an alien world.
They look very different to
anything that we have today.
The name of this organism,
this is Hallucinogenia,
mainly because it perplexed
people quite a bit.
We're not sure exactly
what it looked like.
But over time, as more and
more fossils were found,
they're able to get a really
good kind of construction,
kind of an idea, a mental idea
of what this organism actually
looked like.
And so the first then
drawings then of the organism
looked something
like this, bizarre.
Well, then that caused quite
a bit of debate and stir.
More fossils were found, and
they decided, well, actually,
they drew this upside down.
So this interesting
little critter,
instead of having these
little spines as legs actually
had these spines on the back.
And now the thinking is that
these are actual predator
avoidance spines, effectively.
So when you see something
like that today,
it basically means, don't
eat me, don't touch me right.
Which is interesting,
because now we
can start to read into the
ecology of what that world was
like, going all the way back
about 500 million years ago.
So these organisms were
quite bizarre and alien.
And the more we know, the more
bizarre and alien they look.
But what's interesting is that
they were really only just
a lucky few of these organisms
during this time that actually
made it through,
left descendants
that today partially
helped fill our world.
So over the course of
history, chance alone wiped
out many of these groups,
they're now extinct,
they're no longer with us.
So chance.
So you don't have to go very
far back in recent biology
to find some pretty
prominent thinkers in biology
arguing that chance and
unpredictability is a very
central component of biology.
So this is Watson and Crick,
co-discoverers of the structure
and shape of DNA.
In 1981, Crick then wrote
a book, Life Itself,
Its Origin in Nature.
And so he has this great quote
in terms of the origin of life.
And so he says here,
the origin of life
appears at the moment
to be almost a miracle.
Effectively, punting the ball.
I don't know.
We've got DNA,
that's enough, right?
Here's Jacques Monod or Monod.
Life is only the
result of pure chance.
So the biosphere doesn't
contain any kind of set or class
of predictable objects, chance.
So does life really come
down to a roll of the dice?
Well, like anything in
biology, to make sense
of not only the organisms
today but also of organisms
in the past and the
origin of life in general,
we ultimately have to understand
the unique selective pressures
of different environments
but also how life evolves.
So this is Dobzhansky, he was
one of the main architects
of modern evolutionary
theory in terms
of our modern understanding
and our modern underpinning
of the role of evolution
within biology.
And he has this fantastic quote
that says, nothing in biology,
underscore nothing, makes
sense except in the light
of evolution.
So what about
evolution and chance?
So 1859, Charles
Darwin publishes
The Origin of Species.
And so chance is actually
an important component
of evolution by
natural selection.
Now, what's interesting is I
have here Darwin's algorithm.
And I do that because, if
you read the last paragraph
in The Origin of
Species, Darwin actually
outlines then the
theory of evolution
by natural selection
as an algorithm.
You can almost think of
this as a computer program.
So if a few truths are
correct, then the end result
must be true, and that
is natural selection.
Now, there is going to be
a quiz on this later on.
So please take some notes.
And I actually ask my
students, incoming students,
if they can basically
outline Darwin's algorithm.
I do that in the
start of every class.
And none of them have gotten
it right at the start,
but they get it right
at the end of course.
So what's the algorithm?
Well, Darwin observed that
organisms or any organism
has the propensity to ultimately
grow in its population size
exponentially.
So take this very cute example
of a bunch of ducks on a pond.
Given enough time, we're
going to be not only filling
the pond with ducks, but
very quickly, that population
is going to be
growing exponentially.
Any population, bacteria, ducks,
elephants, given enough time,
that population
rate of growth is
going to be growing
exponentially
to the point where it could be
growing at the speed of light.
Imagine populations of elephants
growing at the speed of light,
clearly that's impossible.
So this is the
insight of Darwin.
Then he said, OK, if that's
true and all these individuals
at some point are
going to be competing,
competing either for
mates, space, resources,
that at some point, because of
this competition for limited
resources, that exponential
growth has to change.
There's a leveling
off, there's a carrying
capacity or a limit to
the number of individuals
and that you can support.
And this is his other insight.
If you look then within any
population, when organisms
are than competing then
for limiting resources,
offspring are going to
differ in their ability then
to compete and obtain resources.
So some individuals are better
in terms of finding mates,
competing for resources.
Now we know that that
variation is ultimately
due to genetic
variation, ultimately
random mutation, chance events
introducing this variation then
into the population.
So according to Darwin, if
and all these things are true
and that genetic
variation is heritable,
then, given all of
the above, you're
going to see
differential survivorship
and/or reproduction.
Some individuals will
survive better as well as
reproduce better, some
combination of the two,
because of which the population
phenotype of the genotype
will then change.
But then the last step, go back
to one, and repeat infinitely.
So that was Darwin's insight.
So I want to emphasize here
that chance events enters
in terms of how variation is
entered into the population.
But I also want you to note
that individuals are competing
for limited resources that
ultimately, then they're using
to fuel then their bodies.
This is the end result.
This is the tree of life.
So what I'm showing you here
at the base then of this plot,
this is time going out
in either direction.
So this is the birth of
the earth then going out
all the way into present day.
So present day then is
the tips of the trees
all the way at the top, ranging
from bacteria, eukaryotes,
plants, fungi, all these
invertebrates, sharks and fish,
amphibians, reptiles, birds, and
mammals, very impressive sweep.
So what's beautiful about
Darwin's insight is that all
of the organisms today,
all that we know,
all can be traced back
to one common ancestor.
That ancestor then
left behind descendants
who left behind
descendants that ultimately
survived to today, populating
the world that we live in.
Now, I want to point out
several very interesting things
about this plot.
If you'll notice, it's
kind of like an onion.
There's these different kind
of circles in there, right?
These onions are actually
marking some very important
Earth history events.
In particular, here is
the Cambrian Explosion,
where all of these different
body plans and body types
come about.
If you follow any one branch,
most of those branches
actually end.
The ending then the branches
then is an extinction event.
But if you'll notice, there's
some pretty large extinction
events.
There have been five
mass extinction events
on the earth, because of
which, on the order of 90%
to approximately 99% of all
species that have ever lived
on the planet are now extinct.
So literally, we are the 1%.
So chance events.
Many of these mass
extinctions are now
pointing back to, just by
chance, a large asteroid hit.
So 65 million years ago,
there was a very large one
that wiped out quite a
bit of life on Earth.
But also 65 million
years ago, also ushered
in a new group of organisms who
before were relatively rare.
So this extinction event ushered
in the age of the mammals
and the extinction
of the dinosaurs.
And it also ushered in
a very interesting niche
art of extinction
events on the internet.
And I have to say that these
are all very bad pieces of art.
I wouldn't want to
put these on my wall,
but somebody spent a lot
of time in designing these.
Maybe you saw this recent study.
So this came out
just a few weeks ago.
This was in the New York
Times, a very large study
on risk of cancer.
What they find is that random
mutations, chance events,
account for about 2/3 of
the risk of getting cancer,
which leaves the other
suspects, heredity,
environmental
factors, accounting
for a very small fraction of
your risk of getting cancer,
chance events.
So two fundamentally
different views of biology.
Chance, but now let's
talk about determinism.
Is life on Earth organized
by a set of general rules
and principles?
The thinking here is
that, well, maybe,
the winners and the
losers may change,
but the rules of the game
have stayed the same.
And if true, what are the rules?
Another book that
I was influenced
by in graduate school
was actually a book
by Harold Morowitz
published in 1970.
And so what we can
ask are, what are
the general aspects of life?
So if we went back and replayed
the tape of life again,
would we likely see
biological constants,
things that repeatedly evolve?
So Morowtiz has a great quote.
The energy that flows
through any sort of system
ultimately organizes
that system.
So he was think of
physical systems,
but also biology
is no different.
Biology ultimately does work.
Biology consumes resources,
converts then those resources
into offspring, and does work.
We can think of biology as also
having a very physical work
component.
So here's the hypothesis.
The hypothesis is
that life on Earth
has emerged in part
deterministically
from the laws of
chemistry and physics
but also evolution
by natural selection
to maximize organismal
power, given the constraints
of the environment.
So what I would
like to do is work
through several
different examples, what
appear to be very
deterministic, very
rule-like aspects of biology.
The first is something known
as the citric acid cycle.
It's a part of your
core metabolism.
So when you take
introductory biology,
you often start with
a review like this.
So this is a typical cell.
You can see all the different
organelles, the nucleus,
the mitochondria, all the
various different components.
Within the nucleus of course,
that's where the DNA is.
But we can take a
completely different view
of all the amazing biology
then that's within the cell.
Now, when I was taking
introductory biology as well
as molecular biology and
biochemistry, when I went in
and I saw it in his chart,
I was like holy bejesus,
do I have to learn all of that?
Very daunting, but
this is also one
of the pinnacles of biology.
This is what happens inside
each of your cell effectively
constantly, every one
of you is doing this,
and yet you're totally unaware.
So biology has been
so successful and very
Byzantine in drilling
down and working out
all then of the connections
of the biochemistry
then of a typical
cell, very complicated.
Now, let's zoom in
on one part of this.
If you notice this
circular part right here,
this is something known
as the citric acid cycle.
What's interesting about
the citric acid cycle
is that it's
ubiquitous, from what we
can tell, across all of life.
Doesn't matter if you're
bacteria, unicells,
multi-cells, animals, plants,
we have the citric acid cycle.
So here's the argument
maybe the TCA cycle
is an energetic
inevitability, maybe
the TCA cycle actually
originated before life that we
know originated.
Here within the TCA cycle,
what you actually see
is several different
molecules linked
to the other in a series
of chemical reactions.
There is some input here,
mainly pyruvate, acetyl CoA.
But don't worry about
all those details,
but if you know a
little bit of biology,
you should recognize
this, because this
is one of the key components
of aerobic respiration.
So if you break down
these sort of sugars
and these sort of
fats or anything,
ultimately, you're going to
be feeding then molecules
into the TCA cycle.
Two Nobel prize is were
given for, effectively,
the discovery of this.
Adolf Krebs then
was the one that
worked out the
full cycle was also
awarded then the Nobel Prize.
It is also known
as the Krebs cycle.
So the core reactions
of the citric acid cycle
likely existed before cells,
before RNA, before DNA.
The thinking is that this
is an autocatalytic network,
an autocatalytic set
then of reactions
where newly created
molecules, then
catalyze then the reaction
of the next molecule.
In general, this is an
energetically favored set
of reactions, effectively,
it gives off then free energy
by this set then of
autocatalytic reactions.
So you can think
of this as a way
to start creating
order before a lot
of these big biological
macromolecules,
before cells, before
molecular replication,
effectively at the start
then, the beginning of life.
Now, what's interesting is that
the derivatives then of the TCA
cycle then feed into
that very complicated map
that I showed you earlier.
Effectively,
sugars, fatty acids,
the production of all of
these different molecules,
nucleic acids, amino acids,
all these various different
cofactors, critical
things that your body
needs to complete
all the biochemistry.
This effectively,
you can think of this
as kind of like the
fountain of all origination
of biological biochemistry.
So the question is, this is
really the first engine then
of biological synthesis.
So I'd like you to think of
this as a spinning wheel.
Every time then this
wheel is cranking around,
producing not only a bunch
of biological molecules,
but we're ultimately
creating stored energy.
Within then the stored
energy ultimately
is used to produce ATP, which is
effectively how we're powering
then all metabolic reactions.
So we're creating then a
bunch of biological molecules,
we're also then creating then
and preserving stored energy.
What's interesting
is that the rate then
of the spin of the
TCA cycles influences
everything, such as how fast
you age, the rate of senescence,
the risk of cancer, and the
overall organism's energy
status.
So how fast the cycle
spins is ultimately related
to a bunch of other biological
phenomena that we study.
Now, one of the big
surprises is that there
are bacteria then on
Earth who actually don't
rely on an oxygen-rich
environment
but actually use the TCA cycle,
but they run it in reverse,
really cool.
So it runs in reverse,
and it does the opposite.
So unlike aerobic respiration,
where you breathe in oxygen
and you breathe out CO2,
if you run it in reverse,
you can actually suck
in carbon dioxide,
and you can then create a
bunch of additional organic
molecules, things like vinegar
and additional molecules
as well, again, some basic
building blocks of life.
So very interesting,
you can run it forward,
you can run it backwards.
And depending on the
local environment,
that would then select
for whether or not
you're running this
forward or backwards.
So here, I'm showing you a
deep sea hydrothermal vent.
So these hydrothermal vents
then are at effectively,
the bottom of the ocean.
This is where your plates
then are splitting apart.
So we have rising magma pushing
our various continental plates
apart but here, because
of all of the magma
underneath in the Earth, we're
getting this really superheated
water in to a bunch of dissolved
minerals and other molecules.
And they're then reacting to
create a very interesting mix
of chemical reactions.
The thinking is that
in this environment,
these hydrothermal vents,
when we actually look today,
we see life teeming around
these hydrothermal vents.
And so what's interesting
is that we can support
an entire ecosystem based on
energy that's actually not
ultimately from the sun
which is most of what's
life in the oceans and the
terrestrial environment relies
on, but ultimately, the source
of energy here is geothermal.
So the thinking is before,
there was life on earth,
these early reactions
of the TCA cycle
were likely present in
these hydrothermal vents.
All of the molecules
that you need in order
to get the TCA cycle
going look to be
present within these
hydrothermal vents.
Now, what's interesting--
we can go back.
I forgot to one
mention one thing.
If you spin this
thing in reverse,
in order to spin it
in reverse, you're
actually not creating
energy, but actually you
have to input energy.
And so that's actually
very interesting.
So if we run it forward,
we're creating ATP.
If we run it
backwards, we actually
have to have energy put in.
So where did this initial
set of molecules to power
the TCA cycle come from?
Well, the thinking is
that this ultimately
came from acetyl phosphate.
And acetyl phosphate is
actually very interesting,
because if you heard the talk
previous to me, Dante talking
about the early Earth
chemistry, based
on the chemistry of
meteorites, if you then
look at the chemistry
of meteorites,
you'll find that there's a
very large supply, apparently,
of phosphorous coming
into early Earth.
Those early phosphorus compounds
in combination with water
looks to easily give
you acetyl phosphate.
So we have all the ingredients.
We have the basic molecules
to start the TCA cycle,
but we also have acetyl
phosphate to power the cycle.
So the TCA cycle appears
to have originated
before the origin of cells,
before RNA, and before DNA.
And it's really this
geothermal energy
that's effectively
provided the environment
and the initial chemistry to get
these initial reactions going.
So remember, if you get
these reactions going,
all one has to do is simply put
those reactions inside a cell
in order to contain
it and then control
the production of these
early biological molecules.
So if this is correct,
our initial view
of the start of life
has actually changed.
What we can actually then see
is that this core metabolism
of the TCA cycle appears to
have been present at the start.
Once we have the
ability to create
some basic biological
molecules associated
with these autocatalytic
set of reactions,
somehow, if we then contain and
harness this core metabolism
within cells, have a
set of genetic material
in the form of
either DNA or RNA,
to somehow not only
control those reactions
but also have natural selection
taking over at that point.
So if we go from back
to the origin of life
3.8 billion years
ago, all the way
to the Cambrian Explosion,
what we actually see
is this core metabolism
staying put and life
just building more and
more complexity on top
of that fundamental core.
Now, within you,
what's interesting
is that you run your a cycle
within these organelles
known as mitochondria.
What's interesting is that the
mitochondria is essentially
this long ghost of an
ancient bacterial symbiosis.
Ultimately your mitochondria
were at one time
free-living bacteria.
Tight living associations
between bacteria
probably provide
beneficial associations,
so much so that the
fact that now, you're
organelles within your
cells appear ultimately
to be traced back to these
early symbiotic relationships
between bacteria.
What's interesting, if
we look at the genes that
are ultimately underlying not
only the production of energy
within the mitochondria
but ultimately
the TCA cycle, this one
associated with ultimately
harnessing this energy gradient,
this gene cytochrome oxidase
is another ubiquitous
gene across biology.
Very little genetic
variability in general.
And we find this
gene that ultimately
is responsible for generating
energy ultimately associated
with TCA cycle being
present throughout most
if not all of life.
So ubiquitous
across all of life.
It's fundamental to
organismal metabolism.
There's even indication that
the TCA cycle itself may
have evolved multiple times.
So ultimately, we're talking
about core metabolism
producing, storing
energy to fuel everything
that an organism does.
OK.
So what's the second
component of life?
What we see repeatedly
across the evolution of life
is very strong
selection to get big.
Multicellularity has evolved
multiple times independently.
So going from
unicellular organisms
to multicellular
organisms again and again
appears to offer a
selective advantage.
So today, the organisms that
we share our planet with
are actually the largest that
have ever lived on Earth.
And you may say, well,
gosh, the dinosaurs
are pretty big, right?
Well, they're easily dwarfed
by this guy, the blue whale.
But the blue whale is actually
dwarfed by the General Sherman
tree, an order of
magnitude larger.
So why is larger better?
Throughout time, we
see this increase
in the size of an organism.
So if you get big,
you can overcome
various physical
forces like viscosity.
If you're very small
and you're in the water,
that can provide a really
hard situation for you
in terms of how you go about
your day to day business.
So if you get bigger, you
can overcome these forces
like viscosity.
But also if you're
bigger, you can
dominate and kind of
maintain larger territories
and control more
and more resources.
If you're also bigger, you
can avoid the competition
of smaller individuals.
If ' use resources that are
differently available to you,
being larger often offers
quite a few opportunities.
If you're bigger, you can
usually do more tasks.
Larger things tend to have
more different cell types,
larger things tend to respond
to the environment differently.
You can also process more and
different types of information.
But also, if you're
bigger, you live longer.
And because of which, you often
then have access to resources
that smaller things don't have.
It's probably not a big
surprise that the biggest
city that's ever been on earth
is actually alive and well
today.
This is Tokyo, 37.6 million.
And just for chuckles
and grins here,
what's the biggest corporation?
Actually, I had no idea
what the Sinopec group was,
but it makes $486
billion per year.
It's the national
petroleum company
of China, which I
guess makes sense.
They're making a
bunch of stuff which
then leads to the second
largest company on Earth, which
sells the stuff.
$476 billion per
year, bigger, better,
can dominate, control
more resources.
So another aspect of general
items that we see across life,
fractals.
Fractals are
interesting because they
seem to be underlying a lot
of themes within biology.
But unlike the genetic
code, which to our knowledge
has only evolved once, we see
a lot of fractal structures
that have mathematically
very similar properties
for many different
functions that
have evolved multiple
times that are effectively
identical to each other.
So you're a great example.
If I boiled away your skin
and looked in your body,
you'd look like this.
You're a sitting tree.
Leaf veins.
Leaves are nice and green,
but if you take away
that outer skin,
they're beautiful,
and this is what
you're left with.
Your lungs.
This could be a root
system, it could
be a branching architecture
of a tropical tree.
Within your brain,
information networks,
these transport
electrical signals for
not only your motor control
but also your learning
and your sensory perception.
What's interesting
is that we can
describe all of these
different networks
and find that they have very
similar mathematical signals
associated with them.
Here's an aquatic example.
This is a modern filter feeder.
This a gorgonian in a coral
reef, And this is a fun one.
So let's go back to
the Burgess Shale.
So they think that this
organism, it's a fossil,
was some sort of an alga,
some algae of some sort.
It's now extinct.
But what's very interesting
is that if we analyze
the branching structure
of these organisms,
you'd be hard pressed
to tell this apart
from a lung or a tree,
oak tree, that you'd
find growing in your yard.
So why these treelike networks?
So one of the projects
that I decided
to focus on when I
was in graduate school
was essentially
asking this question.
Why is it that we tend to see
these branching morphologies
throughout most of biology?
It doesn't matter if
you're a plant or an animal
or even within a
cell, we tend to see
these sorts of structures.
So here's the argument.
So evolution by
natural selection
actually favors this sort of
network, because it's optimal.
And we would expect to see these
networks anytime in biology
where resources are limiting and
where competition or limiting
resources is keen.
Because these networks, they
tend to be space filling,
they fill some sort of space.
But what's also interesting
is that-- here's
a little bit of lingo-- they
tend to be area preserving.
And these are just fancy ways of
saying that, by space filling,
these networks maximize
resource exchange surfaces.
Organisms are exchanging
resources from the environment
into their body, and
they're transporting
within their body
or their cells,
ultimately to fuel metabolism.
These networks are also
designed so that they
minimize transport costs.
So you can boil this down.
These networks give you the
biggest bang for the buck.
You can take in a bunch of
resources or information,
transport them within
the body to fuel
all of your central nervous
system or your metabolism
at a minimum cost.
So the result then are networks
that maximize energy throughput
at a minimum cost.
We're in the homestretch here.
Last part.
Life is characterized by
a set of scaling laws.
And as a result, and this
is really interesting,
the rate of aging is
actually scaled in a way
so that all of life
actually fluxes
about the same amount
of energy per unit mass
across all living things.
And they say, my goodness.
That sounds really
quite remarkable.
But I would like you to
consider for a moment
these wonderful and
amazing organisms.
They do very different things.
They feed on
different resources.
Some of them live a short
time, others live a long time.
So what I'm to do is only
take all those organisms,
and I'm going to
put them on a graph.
So at the bottom, I have
their body size or their mass.
You pick them up, you weigh
them, you put them on a scale.
On the y-axis, I'm going to plot
a measure of how fast they're
producing biomass, how
fast they're growing.
So remember that growth
is fueled ultimately
by the TCA cycle.
So let's look at insects,
birds, fish, plants,
unicellular all the way up to
multicellular plants, mammals,
protists, zooplankton.
And what was really interesting
is that recently, we
were wondering if we could
put long-extinct organisms
on this plot.
And what's really interesting,
in the bones of dinosaurs,
if you cut open their
bones and their fossils
and you look then
at the bones, what
you'll actually find with things
that look like tree rings.
So just like a tree
when you cut it down
it has growth rings, a
lot of different organisms
than that leave behind
bone, you can also
measure their growth rate.
If some basics of how
to convert that to mass,
we have estimates of where
the dinosaurs would be,
things long extinct.
So this is interesting.
All organisms are
described, apparently,
by an approximate
general scaling function.
As you go across scales of
size, we know how they grow.
What's interesting
is that plot says
that the total amount of energy
a very small organism or a very
big organism uses per unit
mass for their entire lifespan
is approximately the same.
It's actually 8 times 10 to the
fifth kilojoules per kilogram.
So this is like the Hitchhikers
Guide to the Galaxy.
Why that number?
I have no idea, but it exists.
Within a mouse, the TCA cycle
is spinning very rapidly.
Within an elephant,
it spins very slowly.
An interesting outcome
of that, if you calculate
the total number of
heartbeats in a mammal,
you can do this for birds too or
anything with a heart-- plants
don't have hearts,
there are actually
very similar numbers for them
but for different quantities.
If you actually plot
out the total number
of heartbeats across
all the mammals,
there's some variability.
But it's about 7.3 plus or minus
5.6 times 10 to the eighth,
about a billion.
Now, I'm sure some of you,
quantitatively astute,
have probably
calculated your number
and found that you
well exceed a billion.
That's all right, there is
some slop in these numbers.
I'm sure you're
going to be fine.
But this is what's interesting.
Why is it about a billion?
Why isn't it 100?
Why isn't it a million?
Why isn't it a trillion?
Why that number?
Well, probably, it ultimately
has to do with the fact
that-- you can just think
of any car that you buy.
At some point, it's going
to wear out, entropy.
But what's interesting
is that we don't really
have a really good
biological understanding
for why these numbers.
Last thing that I'm going
to end on, ecosystems.
So if you think
about an ecosystem,
you can have a trophic
network, that is who eats who.
So you can have plants,
herbivores eat the plants,
larger carnivores
eat the herbivores,
you have secondary carnivores,
tertiary carnivores,
carnivores eating carnivores.
It gets really messy.
Now, if you think about an
ecosystem, that dissipation
of energy, either from
the deep sea vents
or from photosynthesis
from the sun,
is dissipated then
through the biosphere
through these trophic
interactions of who eats who.
But remember, that energy is
all being paced and scaled
ultimately by what's happening
not only in your mitochondria
but also down to the core
metabolism of the TCA cycle.
So we can talk about
ecosystem-scale metabolism.
We can talk about the
metabolism of the biosphere.
So what I'm showing
you here actually,
this is some work led in
part by Neil Martinez.
Neil is one of my
colleagues here
at the University of Arizona.
And Neil and his
colleagues went through
and they did a fantastic study.
So they looked at these
networks of interactions.
So you can kind of think of this
as any other kind of network
of interactions, like on
Facebook or the internet,
kind of like who's
connected to who.
But here, what we're
doing is, we're
looking at a trophic network in
terms of having the plants here
at the bottom, then the
herbivores, who eats who
in terms of which herbivores
are on which plants but also
the top carnivores here in
terms of who are they eating.
So what's actually
very interesting is,
I'm showing you two of these
different trophic networks
or food webs.
One of them is from
the Burgess Shale.
The other is from a lake,
probably in Wisconsin.
Now, what's interesting
is that statistically,
you can analyze than the
degree of connectedness
then of this network.
And in general, you can't tell
them apart from each other.
Their network of
interactions are organized
in a very similar way.
So when we look at these
networks of interactions
remember, we're seeing the
dissipation of metabolic energy
throughout the ecosystem.
And those interactions
are organized in a way
so that metabolism
is then passed
through all the
way from herbivores
up to the carnivores.
So what I'm showing
you here is one view
of the metabolism of the earth.
This is carbon
assimilation, how much
carbon is coming into
the terrestrial biosphere
via photosynthesis.
And this movie is looping
through at a monthly timestep,
every month.
And so if you watch
it, what you'll see
is you'll see seasonalities
during the year.
So the Northern Hemisphere
will green up in the summer,
but when winter comes,
it'll brown down.
You'll also see within the
tropics and South America
and Australia and Asia.
You'll see, even
within the tropics,
the pulsing of
terrestrial metabolism
to flux throughout the year.
And you can watch this.
This goes out actually, for
many, many different years.
But this is variation
in ecosystem metabolism.
Now, if you're interested,
we can talk about this later,
but I don't have the time.
But I will tell you
that you can take
what we know of
core metabolism, you
can take our knowledge of
how fast the TCA cycle spins,
you can take the different
sizes of organisms
that we know exist to actually
predict the metabolism
at the scale of an ecosystem.
And we can trace that
metabolism all the way down
to the core
metabolism ultimately
down to the TCA cycle.
So the Earth is literally
a metabolizing entity,
ultimately fueled by a
set of core reactions
that are ubiquitous
across all of life.
And that dissipation of
energy, both within organisms
and across ecosystems,
appears to also
be governed by general rules
with how natural selection has
maximized not only
distribution networks,
but also control the
interactions of who eats who
and how energy is dissipated.
So to summarize,
general aspects of life.
Life does work.
Metabolism maintains
homeostasis.
So right now, your body
is working very hard
to maintain your core
temperature around a very
small degree of fluctuation.
Any deviation from
that is deadly.
You spend a lot of
energy trying to maintain
your core metabolism temperature
at a very constant level,
homeostasis.
Life in general evolves,
becoming increasingly larger
and larger and larger.
This doesn't mean that
small organisms disappear.
There's plenty of different
places for small organisms
to live.
But larger organisms
effectively by becoming larger,
they avoid the competition
from smaller ones
but can exploit and dominate
more and more resources.
Life uses fractal networks.
They appear to
optimize transport
in terms of time and flow.
Again, natural selection appears
to be doing the optimization.
Life itself is scaled
by core metabolism.
This has remained constant
across all scales.
But life's interactions in terms
of the struggle for resources
to fuel metabolism is
ultimately scaled and paced
by the core rate of
metabolic reactions.
So in general, the
diversity of life
is shaped by this flow
and dissipation of energy.
So I started with this
dichotomy within biology
that we have both a
deterministic and also
a chance view on life.
So determinism, there are
regular deterministic processes
that shape the diversity of
life, the laws of chemistry,
physics, combined with
evolution by natural selection
appears to be very general in
terms of many different aspects
of life.
Again, these rules appear
to ultimately determine
not only the pace of life
but also the functioning
of Earth's ecosystems.
But we also know that there
is a big component of chance
as well.
Random mutations are a key
component of evolution.
Extinction at many levels
happened constantly.
Because of these
extinction events,
ecosystems undergo
rearrangements.
So let's try to
put this together.
Well, life in general is both
by chance and deterministic.
Even though the players
of the game have changed,
it looks as if there are
some general rules that
have remained the same.
And I've showed you five
general aspects of life
on Earth which are
tantalizing and suggest
that if we did find
life elsewhere,
and if resources are limiting,
so there is competition
for limiting space,
resources, or mates,
we may expect to see these
aspects of life repeated there.
And so this is
interesting to ponder
once we do start looking for
life in the next several talks,
what that life may look like.
So I would like to
thank many folks who
have inspired not only this
research but also this talk,
in particular Eric Smith and
Geoffrey West at the Santa Fe
Institute, but also
my lab group, Joaquin,
and many folks that underlie
the production staff here
at the science series.
But with that, I want to
say thank you for your time.
It's been a pleasure.
Thank you.